a lot of people are asking me like
what's the hbo max show going to be
and then i don't know how this happened
but when it was first announced
the descriptor was it's going to be a
new variety show yeah yeah starting code
enterprise that cracked me up a a format
that i think peaked like in 73.
yeah well i know exactly why that
happened which is uh someone
uh in the machinery somewhere uh i think
at the at the network threw the word
variety in there because we're in the
variety
comedy
category right which is an old term
that's just an old term comedy variety
category so really broad so literally i
think a lawyer just said
anyway
literally a lawyer
at somewhere in the bowels of some
massive i'm thinking uh you know a
building in mordar
said oh what do we call it well it's
comedy variety so just say a variety
program so anyway that hit the press
and i had friends saying so you're
bringing back the old variety show
seriously yeah and
so
this is a true story
i met someone who was trying to get in
touch with me who's a uh a juggler and a
magician oh my god who said i would be
perfect for your new variety
a variety
30 years
and i and i think ship's coming in that
people thought that i'm going to you
know it's going to be
it's the cone show
put on your hat it's the conan show try
on some spats you're gonna have a laugh
give birth to a calf it's the conan show
today
and then there'd be all these dancers
with red wigs on and then i'd come out
it's conan
and i'd come out and go like hey how's
it going
microphone yeah giant conan letters we
got it yeah we got a great show today
but first of all
and then i do a song and then you
birthed the calf yeah exactly and then
uh you know let's get to my first guest
uh from uh dynasty john forsythe we're
gonna pretend to be cabbage patch dogs
we're on this shelf and no one's buying
us and i'm not buying this [ __ ]
and anyway uh that is completely not
what's gonna happen what did that person
say when you told them uh they were
juggling as they asked me and when i
said there'll be no juggling they
dropped all the balls and the chainsaw
and now his name is laffy
but
what i'd like to do is something that
does not come on every night obviously
because uh um
and i've just i've been thinking we have
this
this world now in this streaming
universe where people can make
fewer of something
maybe it comes on once a week
and i'm thinking i really want to double
down on the things that i love that
we've talked about on this show
which involves getting out of the studio
and
combining a bunch of the elements that i
think
maybe make me a little different because
whatever i do i don't
obviously i'd like it to be
something that might
contribute or feel like it's
needed there's so many late night shows
now
and i've done so much of that i feel
like it should be something that is
more unique to me
and something that
uh maybe
we can spend a little more time crafting
and
i have a lot of ideas i have a lot of
very specific ideas and
you'll be seeing this coming your way
in no time
keep your eyes peeled and if you don't
have hbo max yet don't get it until
my show shows up
and then get the free trial and then
watch them all yeah
then cancel it
i think that the show's gonna be called
watch me on the free trial only